[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
Jacqueline alongside Mr Mark Ellis and
we are in spooky season we're we're in
the heat of it yes again there's pumpkin
in the air I to say the psls I'm sorry I
feel last episode I shaded you a bit for
that pumpkin is a very big part of fall
I but I didn't realize that I was that I
was okay here's I I I make a big
distinction in my mind between pumpkin
spice latte season and pumpkin spice
because I got this candle that I'm
really excited about and Happ be pumpkin
spice and what did I tell you I like it
not because it reminds me of going to a
coffee chain it reminds me of football
season so I like the candle lit because
it's like the crispness in the air and
and and still optimism about my team in
midt can happen our guess our guess can
back me up on this but I was still a
black woman listening to a white person
wax about pumpkin spice and I was kind
of like this is something I've lived
before you heard it all too much and I
was like you want to break out that
friend's box set this go drag to hell
drag H what else about him his his uggs
and scarf is a Christian
girl I did say North Face jacket I did
get that card together well this is this
is so bad I feel bad for him because we
outnumber him today and this is like a
great moment I will say because I'm
bringing my friend also an incredible
podcast or host our friend mutual
friends Mutual friends we will fight
over it in the comments but Akila Hugh
she's an author and the founding host of
cricked media's what a day podcast and
also happens to see me and Mark outside
of Studio locations how you doing lady
welcome to the so good thanks for having
me it feels overdue but also we've all
been on strike and all kinds of crap so
like who knows time is a construct
thanks for having me and and and you
will you are freshly off strike which I
love from uh one of your unions and we
are soon to be off strike from both been
back at it so knocking on the wood
knocking on the wood I can't stay hot
forever Hollywood's going to have to get
off the pot I'm sorry pooper get off the
P I mean honestly I'm glad you put that
there because that is the reason why I
love this movie and why the score is so
wrong because the sex that this movie
gave us it was such a sexy movie it gets
a 10-point curve just for how many
fantasies it unlocked oh my God this
movie so this is a movie that again this
is one of those weird movies that like
it did it made money to the Box
everybody knew this movie was coming out
everybody was aware of it everybody
still is aware of it this might even
pass the True Romance test where this
movie is even more like well known from
like gen Z because it just keeps having
these new lives and and people
discovering it and me included in that
because I was aware of it forever last
night was the first time that I watched
the craft yeah the 1996 classic 57%
rotten on the Tomato Meter 65% audience
score this is a film that I think when
we look back on it is just so
quintessentially '90s but it is
obviously going to be something that
ranks high on our 100 best 90s horror
movies but it's also included in our
book Rotten movies we love under cult
leaders because it was just that iconic
and I again it the sad truth is it took
us so long but I appreciate on this
episode that for R and tomatoes is wrong
we brought two Suburban black girls to
it where the film only brought one head
on over to rotten tomatoes.com check out
the editorial 90 best horror movies or
pick up a copy of our book but before we
Dive In Too Much deep into all of this
Witchcraft and spooker which is I mean
and just days after the the fall equinox
we are doing this right on time sir do
you think you can now having dived into
the pool of The Craft give us an
accurate synopsis I might have to light
a pumpkin spice candle if that's okay
the mood a little bit exactly you're
going to get ran out of here I think you
can and I really want you to do this
because it's going to be great no well
okay it's fresh in my mind and again I
was excited to see it I did feel like I
knowledge this was a gap in my viewing
history that I needed to rectify and
this film I will say when I first saw
that this was what we were watching that
we were having a keil on I was like oh
it's interesting that she picked that
movie with Sandra bul and Nicole Kidman
and then I was so I was kind of
expecting it you thought was the other
witchie if you asked me about Practical
Magic versus The Craft I could tell that
they were two different movies but I
just had my head that I was watching
those two stars and then I put on the
craft I'm like oh no no no this is
something else but you also have a lot
of DNA pre-s scream in this movie um so
this film is about a a group of young
ladies three young ladies looking for
their fourth not like another friend but
their fourth to complete this circle of
Witchcraft that they all investigate
like every person in high school does
they have a hobby they get into a click
they're definitely not well-liked by the
jocks or by the the the cheerleader sect
right so they go off in the woods
there's a lot of woods in this movie
there's a lot of Southern California
Wilderness where you go and you just
like getting away from your parents
casting spells reading about stuff going
into these storefront you know Wiccan
kind of shops and then all of a sudden
we find that we do have some Powers lo
and behold and what happens when you get
a little bit of power oh my God that
Apple tastes so good I'm just going to
finish this whole thing to the core that
gets rotten and they get too uh they get
too you know High fluting and a couple
of them need to be taken down a Peg and
that's our adventure and some people
have some pretty gruesome exits along
the way real bad yeah all that all that
dude wanted to do was hold a snake and
show it to people and uh yeah hate to
see it hate to see it so we'll spoil
that Ending by the time we get into
movie talk but that is what the movie
The Craft is about yeah well since you
did gave us that great synopsis and
because you are fresh with it were you
surprised at the 57% do you think Rotten
Tomatoes was wrong I think Rotten
Tomatoes was wrong I I think that at
even at the time because this movie
feels so stuck in the 90s but also very
Progressive even for where we are now as
far as just like you know talking with
women in 2023 as I'm as a single fellow
is lot to do talking with women like the
old joke used to be I you know it's hard
to date somebody uh my age or younger
because I'm not an astrologist right
like I don't know when this planet's in
retrograde but seeing how seriously
people take all of this kind of lore
like I I had a girlfriend before that
y'all both know and one of the very few
rules that I had when she was moving in
was I'm no Ouija boards in this oh wow
by the way he's being euphemistic but
like a gateway drug yeah no totally she
is a gateway D she will read those tarot
no she she would always even today she's
like oh no let me do a tar I'm like get
that stuff away from me like the cult
stops at the door what do I always say I
don't believe in it but I don't not
believe in it believe enough in it to
fear it only if it's good news I have a
yeah I didn't want the good news I
because as this movie proves if you get
a little bit of good news yeah it always
comes back three-fold the other way so
no thank you so I'm gonna ask you then
Aila first of all I want to know how you
feel about witchiness because he is
right like California and that was
literally my point I was going to say is
like there's certain things you get in
California tattoo uh a weed habit and
like a Tarot reader like those are the
things that like perfect the weed haveit
and the trainer to borrow some of Mark's
lines like those are like that is like
the LA starter K get a trainer you
figure out how to parket Trader Joe's
that kind of like it's part of it so how
do you feel about the witchy stuff in
real life and in movies and then how
wrong do you think the score is okay so
what I will say and this might surprise
people is that I am not super witchy I I
like Halloween but I'm I would say
horror is probably my like biggest blind
spot as far as like genres go uh because
I just I that kind of anxiety and like
Dread is the worst feeling like it's
like a roller coaster for me but it's
all down like the whole time I'm like
are we ever going to come up a little
bit like rest the bit it's scary I'm not
having fun oh my God so I actually
resisted seeing this movie forever I saw
it last year for the first time wow it
wasn't a big part of my childhood like I
had some Halloween birthday friend so
sleepovers would happen and I was the
one with toothpaste on my face cuz I
went to bed at 7:00 p.m. I was like you
girls have
um straight up like I'm not staying up
to do the like light as a feather stiff
as a board I love that we were all old
people even back in high school
cuz I'm ready to go to bed I do not want
to talk to youall about anything right
you're going to DARE me to eat dog food
and I'm going to say no and now I'm the
loser all right so you know this is just
all out of my wheelhouse um and and even
now I think that I still am a New Yorker
in that way where I'm like yeah yeah you
can do your little witch crap around me
but I'm not I don't know if I buy it
like is it a coven or is it a potluck
you know what you know what is so funny
let is it networking or is it a COV fair
fair and one thing that a lot of the
more toxic communities on the internet
has proved us is most people just need
friends like they would believe that the
Earth is flat if it gave them friends
right and you you look at the robin
tun's character in this movie she
basically she just she shows up and
she's new and she's like who wants to be
friends with me uh the guys are kind of
giving her some
some looks the the cool girls want
nothing to do with her so it's like I
guess I'm down to the witches exact and
then I just happen to be good at it I to
be exactly I'm only now finding out that
I Michael Jordan of Witcher unbel I
needed a friend first yes exactly and
that's the Gateway so I would
say unpopular opinion I think that the
score is
accurate just south of fresh just south
of fresh Jason and I I do think that you
know the real issue is that scream has
just overshadowed it to such a degree
like and I I wasn't able to sleep
through that one they really held me
down and made me watch with my eyes open
they're like you're GNA be terrified of
this serial killer um so I think that
like when I saw the movie because it was
so much later I was like this is a lot
of the cast but is it bringing like Nev
Campbell come on like she's so good in
Scream the whole time I'm like Sydney I
can't so so we brought a scream head to
fight that's fine I'm not going to lie
to you we can we can have a good put
down your ghost face mask we're not
talking about let it I'll let it go for
this fair cuz you all are my friends and
I love the Pod but I I will say that
when I realized that was the sort of
crew uh you know the real the real only
difference is that they do have a person
of color in this one I'm sorry that was
enough for me cuz Rachel true was like
the Avatar with her and cre and just
like them that was the main thing that I
loved about the craft and still love
about the craft like don't be wrong fuza
the style I really love Rachel's outfits
I've definitely cosplayed as her and a
Halloween but at that time that
character was faking groundbreaking this
was 1996 when it was always just the
same for white girls it was always just
the same for whatever so like even
having her in the movie in my personal
opinion was a huge part of it and one of
the things I want to talk about I will
say I think Ryan Tomatoes is wrong but
actually y'all be surprised I think it
is just a little bit slightly better I
looked at Cru and attention score and it
was like low low to high 60s I think
Brian like double check me if I'm right
on that but that's where I think this
one should be Cruel Intentions really I
would not have picked so first of all I
would which one would you say is better
cruel intention Cruel Intentions yeah
all right can I tell yall something yeah
you've never seen it have you oh you
have to do this one so where is it write
it down4 54 see less so that's what I'm
saying like like like Cruel Intentions
holds up basically what I'm saying put
we need this same exact table for cruel
in I'll be back next week I think Cru
intentions has gone down because it used
to be in the 60s I did know that it was
in the 60s because it was in the book in
the 60s anyway whole point being 80%
audience 80% the audience is right it's
enjoyable I mean for the record I would
put the craft where the audience has it
like mid maybe high 60 right I would say
that I would say Rotten Tomatoes maybe
is off but the audience 65 sure look
sure it was still a movie that was
marketed to teen specifically to teen
and tween girls which again that is a
complete genre of film making that has
gone the way of the dinosaur now like
hot topic was starting to like crop up
in sure trying to sell some chokers it
it this felt like Twilight of the night
where it's like everybody who is walking
out of this theater probably has a new
hobby that they can't wait to get into
exactly um let's also go ahead and take
a peek though and see what people were
saying back in 1996 because I do feel
like this is a movie that is very much
of the moment meaning that whatever we
think about it whether it be good or bad
was directly related to how people felt
about again teenage girls at that time
yeah totally all right Brian C the
music in some ways the craft is pure
1996 from the cloth to the soundtrack
which includes cuts from the likes of
Heather Nova Letters to Cleo Matthew
site and
Elastica in other ways it can feel like
clueless is black clad cousin given that
it was released a year after and also
featured a cast full of upand cominging
talent but even if the craft is heavy
with Gen X trappings it's a movie that's
much more than just a time capsule the
craft was a sleeper hit when it was
first released in theaters and it's
enjoyed a cult following ever since
enough that a sequel the craft Legacy
was finally released in 2020 it didn't
do quite as well with critics however
who praised the cast in the film's
empowering message but were less
impressed with the movie so so special
effects and its Reliance on cliche
plotting the craft is rotten at 57% on
the Tomato Meter with 60 reviews and it
has a 65% audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a rotten review
Jane gonnell of the San Francisco
Examiner wrote despite the heroic
efforts of four promising young
actresses in the starring roles in a
Nifty premise the movie is a mess so
incoherently plotted that dramatic
tension doesn't have a chance to build
however in a fresh review Dave Kerr of
the New York daily news wrote with its
sense of what can be accomplished on a
small budget the craft suggests the
classic be horrors of the' 40s
particularly the cat people and the
seventh victim the Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus reads the crafts can't
be magic often overrides the feminist
message at the story's core but its
appealing cast in post-modern
perspective still cast a sporadic spell
so that's the craft let's Ki it back to
Jacqueline and Mark now is the time this
is the hour theirs is the magic theirs
is the power wow he got the tagline I
love it when he has a little tagine I'm
not even saying that stuff cuz like I
see what it does in the movie and I'm
like no thanks right why no thanks why
risk it things have been bad enough
listen we just got the negotiating
committee to get us back in business I
can't risk now and if you don't think
there were some witches on the side of
that happening come on I know there were
covin working overtime for the past 146
days to get this stri my football team
just got rid of the worst owner in the
history of professional sports and you
want to mess with this magic I'm hit me
up in January the thing I will say is
this since I get to um as we head into
movie talk before we head into movie
talk I will represent the witchy
Community well because I just want to
say between the two of you I've felt the
slander so let's get into movie
[Music]
talk it's a healthy side of fear going
with that slander like I'm not a witch
but I don't want to upset you so I want
to be very clear I grew up up in a very
Christian household and it's so funny to
me that Christians are so against like
religion and the Occult when they
program you to be hella superstitious
and Hell about rituals and rights and so
when you let that go that's when you
find people they go to other places and
I'm definitely one of those people
because I do believe that there's
certain things that are like prevalent
it's like certain herbs and certain
spices and certain things it's like yeah
energy that you put out pumpkin
spice pumpkin spice own wit stage okay
more like yes C people have you ever had
a person walk into a room and completely
change the energy with their attitude
with their attitude like in my personal
opinion in my personal opinion if you
put the right things in the air that
could also like counteract that and
that's like part of like what I think
things like the craft key into now do I
think it's going to make me beach a
bunch of whales and fly no it could
though but can it alter the energy and
The Vibes and to know like the right
time for the energy and The Vibes like
the fact that all these celebrities have
broken up right right when Venus hit
retrograde I'm just sorry I mean also
you know the
strike they saw it coming to a close and
like do I want to be a merging with this
person again like after the pandemic we
made it halfway for us Union folk it is
like coming out of a pandemic after the
strikes you I will say this not to like
take it someplace else before we go deep
diving into the craft but remember those
pandemic breakups like the minute people
went home they're like I can't live with
you yeah they're like the whole point of
our marriage is that I don't have to see
you have to there was also the other
people were like they got all coupled up
in the pandemic and then they didn't
know how to be the couple outside of the
pandemic afterwards I think that's this
current wave of breakups like that's the
like like we're really good at doing
puzzles together but now that we're
allowed outside like I don't know who
you are yeah like I don't really ever
want to be at a party with you I mean
one thing that this is a theory that I
have is that um any of the celebrities
that you you didn't see during the
strikes at all you're just like that
person's really like I usually see them
they're usually in the news I think this
is the time A lot of people are getting
plastic
yeah we're going to get a lot of new
faces this sh up those hair plugs right
I actually do not agree with you I saw
an actor the other day and someone was
like oh why did he Buzz his hair and I
was like he went to Turkey let's talk
about and it was not for the scenery um
so you both caught the craft later I
can't first of all how is it just cuz it
was horror well I also so I was a kid in
the 90s and I just don't think that I
was allowed to watch it like I I
remember it coming out because I think
does it come out after scream screams
like 95 I actually looked it up because
again like Nev Campbell's in this and
ski Al's in it too and so I'm like oh
major it's actually May 3rd 1996 when
this came out then scream in December of
96 and just ate its cake and so I
remember that like that next fall when
it was on VHS or whatever the Boys and
Girls Club showed it for the sleepover
they showed scream but they didn't show
the craft and so it's like I I really
had no entry point and then by the time
I was old enough we were in like a very
different place in horror like I it
would have been a retrospective even in
high school so I just felt like I missed
it because of the age I was and the
genre it was um and also I think by the
time I got to high school all my witchy
friends had like sort of like made their
coven and I was clearly not you were too
cool to be in the coven yeah I was just
in choir like I was doing other stuff I
was definitely not the C back then this
is this was definitely a thing like it
was um it was the joke in Austin when
you got to Austin you get tattoos and
you get a dog I do believe like a Tarot
habit is part of the thing out because
this is the other thing the weather is
too calm and you have like less like
environmental stresses so you have to
worry about wavelengths out here you
know it's not like you're worried about
rain you got to be worried about like
you know where you're saying like so
like people in Buffalo don't get into
witchcraft because they're busy
shoveling
snow also I just think that like I mean
to be really sort of like theological
it's like they're just there's not a ton
of religion on the west coast so like
this is the religion actually the
religion like we act like we're somehow
different but I'm like no you just chose
thisy that is very true it is nothing
think back and like remember how scared
of like Witchcraft and like like even
like people like parents groups burning
like Harry Potter books and stuff like
that a little a couple years later but
the fact that your boys and girls club
is like okay we got the craft and scream
um like that we were cool with slashers
murdering team but it's like no girls
are playing light as a feather stiff as
a board we don't want our kids seeing
that like they're going to start doing
that in the game room which they we
absolutely did and I don't I just know
it was middle school so this was either
sixth grade or seventh grade yeah did
you see were you a theater kid did you
see this in the theater we saw it in a
classroom I know for a fact that this
ended up being like wish she went to
your the last day of school movie like
when it was on VHS so I guess that would
have been 97 so that was yeah that was
like my going into my eighth grade year
or maybe going into my seventh grade
year whichever one that ending my
seventh grade year yeah going in my
eighth grade year that was when that
happened so yeah I'm like I'm I'm such a
dummy when it comes to watching movies
anyway like I never predict what's going
to happen or anything I was legit thrown
for a loop when the girls started tur on
each other really well as as soon as um
uh you know every woman's like surprised
huh F of black gets all it gets like
that that superpower right like in the
middle of this movie and then and then
you can clearly see like oh that's the
one Vick valor's the one that's like
kind of going to go nuts and we got to
stop her but like up to that point I was
waiting for like one of the bullies to
emerge as like this more overing kind of
thing we took care of them so quickly
Christine Taylor you you racist piece of
garbage let's get the boils on the head
and let's let's let's put a spell on SK
and let bre and Meer giggle at him and
we're done with everybody else and now
we just got now it's about the co itself
Ben Stiller's ex-wife wife at that time
like I think they were like they're not
together anymore I'm missing it was at
the pandemic oh no yeah I didn't know
that either yeah they're not together
anymore yeah uh but no that one there
honestly to the the fusa bulk of it all
because this was after water boy mhm
which was what like no this was
pre-water boy was this pre-water Prat
boy is this pre-water boy what did she
do oh no this is after Return to Oz this
is after Return to Oz and after the
worst witch so like after she was a
child star yeah and this is when she
became the bad girl of the 90s that we
all sort of like like she was the um the
girl from Orange is the New Black before
she was the girl from Orange is the New
Black yeah what was her name uh the one
that played patani oh oh um uh Taran
Taran yes tan Manning Taran Manning she
was the Taran Manning of the 90s like
the the kind of weird off-kilter white
girl that you could say was from the
trailer park yeah right totally but I
was reminded watching this movie how
great she is in just ac across her
filmography cuz she also has a smaller
part and Almost Famous but she's so fun
like she's so good and she's actually
such a captain all all four of them one
of the things I liked about this movie
why I would make it fresh is because
their chemistry particularly with the
three that are already in there and like
will they won't they letting this forth
in there I really like I I believe that
they were like best buds in high school
and they and they they had a good time
like going into these like stores and
looking at all these like like like
potions and books and all that stuff
riding the bus
that store freaks me out I'm not going
into that store I don't ever want to see
the B sides of the witch store that's
not for me no and then remember the
beginning when like she they're like oh
what's behind here and the store owner's
like you're not you're not supposed to
be in there I'm like don't go in there
let's talk about that store owner she
seem to be by the way another example of
every aspect of movies like this is the
adults are clueless like there's never
an adult that has anything going for
them but the shop owner who seemed to
just be like hm these four crazy girls
with impulse issues who getting really
into the occult nothing bad could happen
let me give them quiet polite warnings
she not believe like it's your sore you
don't believe in witchcraft enough to be
like this might be a problem yes oh see
I think she KN I think she was like
Thanos I think I think she knew all this
stuff was going to happen she was like
and then she like let me invoke you and
you go fight the Crazy Girls you're an
adult lady like
do she was the Puppet Master she loved
watching all this stuff play out you
right and and let's face it she does
have a lot of stuff going on outside of
the store yeah she's no one's really
coming in either it's not like the store
was bustling when they came in she was
like oh finally my my regular that's
probably why she did it she's like these
the only buying stuff at this
going to keep it open keeping it open at
the the place with the Catholic school
where everyone goes yeah I'm sure she
had lines out the door uh
the she's always about to close like
getting the sign up and they're like
here we come with
$15 got any more Sage yeah the only
regar at her store steal it and she
knows they steal she's like she's
encouraging this Behavior at the very
least she's like maybe they'll show with
their friends their friends will be
above board and coming by something is
she the witch version of the mom who's
like okay you girl you girls can drink
but it's got to be at my back she poer
and me and girls I I want to ask you
this though about the craft in
particular because it was a movie at the
time that played in really great with
girl fans service like what she does to
ski olr in that movie every girl wanted
to do that to the guy who wasn't calling
him cuz ladies in gentleman and Jen zers
let's remind you this was back when you
had to be at home for his call so if a
guy said he was going to call you and he
didn't call you were literally like at
home waiting for them to call this is
like before the age of cell phon so it
was even more infinitely rude and so
that aspect of the fan service the
aspect of changing your apparel the the
obvious you know part of the kid that
was ordinary and Outcast becoming the
cool kid because whatever it was is no
longer bad about them that is the stuff
where I'm like oh of course this was
popular at that time do you see any of
that like do you what do you pinpoint as
like okay it wasn't for me but I get why
this was so popular yeah I mean I think
all of what you just said is exactly it
like it's a fantasy for especially
teenage girls to feel like they have
power and like these these young women
end up with a lot of it and so I think
being able to just see that on and also
like it feels Justified for most of the
film where you're like okay this is like
these people are terrible like you know
a little bit of the get out before get
out where you're like these racists are
just going to get away with saying this
to this woman or this like teen it's and
no one's stepping in to like help you
know I think a lot of teenage girls want
to be able to rely on themselves and
they they found each other and that was
cute also just like this is the era of
Spice Girls so you have to understand
like girl power is everything and so
until the point in the film where they
start to turn on each other there is
this sort of like wow like you could
have a group of girlfriends just change
the weights of the scales in the school
and like you know uh sort of correct
some things so I think that that's
really good I also think like the
fashion the makeup it's very iconic like
in the same way that clueless was where
it was like these are it's of a Time the
fact that like they don't really talk
about the socioeconomic status but
everybody has a style um and none of it
is like super ugly or too out there it
feels like it could exist where you live
anywhere um I think there's just
something about it that feels very cool
and nostalgic and even then it was like
if I was in high school I would have
been like we are those girls yeah it's
it's got such a teen Rebellion quality
to it where like you look at these Care
at these four leads right and they all
have some version of the Catholic school
uniform that they're required to wear
but it's also like tricked out with all
these other you know like the necklaces
and and like the things that they got
from the store
all that other so it's like Co
counterbalance and the scene that really
like hooked me is when I love the lce of
feather stiff aort scene I thought that
was so cool because then the movie
starts being almost like this superhero
origin story where who's going to break
good who's going to break bad like we
have basically the force who's going to
be a Sith who's going to be a Jedi and
then the scene on the beach man when
they like we realize just how powerful
we are yeah like you could ruin the
world literally and I think that was
when it got scary though I didn't love
that scen like looking back on it
because the minute that happens is when
I'm like oh this is somebody's going to
die yeah it apparently got scary onet
too because director Andrew Fleming he
was uh I think he was saying something
like the scene where they're casting uh
Manon I guess is like the entity yeah um
that that apparently M there's a there's
a gayc god of the sea named manaan or or
something like this very close every
time that they would say the name Manon
the the waves got like like crash and
and like louder and like like noticeably
thunderous and then when they said the
name Mana one time all the first time
they said it the power went out like all
the like like stuff all the lights and
cameras like went down and like that's
where it's like dude you're you're
you're you're knocking on a door and
there's stuff on the other side of it
yeah the one thing I will give this
movie as much as I like it there's
aspects of it now that I feel the reason
why it maybe didn't live in it let's be
real these women came together and then
they immediately turn on each other in
like a very vicious way it's almost like
if you really think about it it's like
yeah that does happen but like just how
this movie played into that there's such
a better version of the story where they
become like the Powderpuff Girls yeah
and like exact revenge and become
something a little bit better but but
they just they never had that team
Dynamic at the beginning like they never
had an agreement in place if we get
these Powers they were just kind of
fumbled around in the dark and lo and
behold yeah Here Comes Here Comes spooky
McGee yeah right yeah they did have
obviously like Wiccan and whatever onset
advisers a great YouTube video if you
haven't checked it out is an actual
witch like watching this movie it's like
my favorite one it's like when the real
life person goes back and looks at him
they just roast him like yeah like
that's not Neil degrass Tyson watching
an outer space movie this is this is we
have Neil degrass Tyson to like sort of
thank for this but it was interesting so
what' she say it was like 50/50 like
like it wasn't great obviously because
she said there's a lot of choices
they're making because it looks good
it's like but there's also some other
ones I do want to talk about too cuz you
talk about the group aspect of this
because they've made a sequel of it and
there's so much of it because the poster
it's all four of them and there's such
this iconic thing but I question what
Andrew Fleming is saying about manau
because we already know that like that
Unity amongst the cast was not actually
accurate like we've come to find out
later that like first of all the girls
were in their early to mid 20s but
Rachel was 30 and so she was always sort
of like separated from the cast in
everything that they did I mean it's I
think that plays out in the plot like
you know like the poster for me is to
your point iconic but then you watch the
film and I feel like there's so many
story lines with her that are just like
well we had to drop that because these
other two girls are fighting like she by
the end I'm like she's kind of the only
one where I'm like let her just wander
off like yeah right go do thing I felt
the same kind of way with uh with Robin
Ton's character's backstory where like
we got like little shades of it but we
never I thought we were going to get
like a little more meat on that bone
like we we we clearly understood where
uh fza black is and her character is
coming from like you just have this this
terrible home situation like obviously
you want to be out of the house out of
the trailer as much as possible because
you don't want to be home like I get
that and then everybody else it's like
they occasionally they dip the toe in
the water of their backstory but we
never get to like really it never felt
fully fleshed out where where they
became more than just like a person in a
movie they they never quite became like
I was rooting for the group and I think
that's why I was so disappointed that
the group turned on each other cuz then
individually I'm like well I don't I
actually haven't fostered much of like
much feelings about any one of you yeah
also bullying is not a great adversary
like you could have either talked it out
talked to a teacher or done the
Witchcraft but like by the time they've
defeated the bullies I'm like so then
what else like and of course they have
to fight each other they're bored now
they're just sitting there like no one's
messing with us there's no one to give
boils to yeah and and the the craziest
thing about that is even in that sort of
like moment it's like when you look at
these characters it was all selfish
Endeavors it was all selfish Endeavors
and that's kind of why it all failed I
guess that's the great lesson of it um
also yeah I just I I wish they would
have turned it into Superman because so
much about it was about the four of them
that's what got girls on it they're like
oh I'm Bonnie and I'm this person
actually everyone wanted to be Rachel or
ful but true
yeah but still yeah they gave an option
for the person in the group who had less
friends and you're like you don't really
get to choose who you
are you're these other two I mean look
it was very much a you could be JC like
JC Lance and the rest of them kind of
situation sorry like JC Justin and then
the rest of them type situation although
now it is JC Lance and the rest of them
sorry guys that is like a very deep ins
synct cut yes let's talk a little bit
about I would say like some of the
amazing scenes because it is like a lot
of great visuals the special effects for
this movie at that time were pretty
groundbreaking like especially when you
get to like the last scene of like I
remember the MTV Movie Awards parody her
whole like flip your head thing that
they were able to do and the uh the
snake pit and all that stuff the snakes
man the snakes Jones level there's so
many snakes and bugs and just all of the
all of the stuff in that in that witch
store and I and I like that's part of
our climax plays out there and that's
where we're kind of discovering who we
can be so that that the owner lady kind
of turned into sort of like an Obi One
where it's like no this power is inside
you too
cuz she almost just seemed like hey like
she never had the talent to go right
exactly yeah she's the teacher she's
those who can't teach she's like I was
good in high school exactly I aged out
but you all have get scholarship right I
didn't get a scholarship to witch school
I didn't get to go to Hogwarts like and
I had to open a store to sell all the
crap that I had crewed over the years
and you all are stealing it how much of
this episode is just us roasting the
shop owner I really do need I just think
that like if they were going to make the
sequel which they did could have just
been this woman like packing up to going
somewhere else because I feel like it
also I mean like to your point it is
California with like the beach and
everything but this to me was like this
could have taken place pretty much
anywhere in America so like let's just
follow her when she gets run out of town
it felt much more like the town in foot
loose than it did someplace in Southern
California where it's like hey we don't
really we we frown upon these Outsiders
doing their weird spells and stuff
totally and I'm like you know no one was
so unse or like uh slovenly in the group
that I'm like I can't believe they're
having these kinds of bullying ISU like
a a one strong parent going to the
school I feel like would have corrected
that not in the '90s really not in the
'90s yeah because you you were you were
labeled a goth kid and you instantly got
like the the Maryland go to that store
one time and now that you're old this is
where your younger Millennial is showing
you guys are old enough to remember
bullying like like and bullying and the
type of bullying they made that movie
The Good Son about like you know what I
mean like the type of bullying that got
you on a mil carton we definitely
experience like but also just the fear
of anything that had to do with
witchcraft or even like there's that
that that that card game magic the
Gathering that like I played early in
the day they banned it and that even
that freaked parents out it's like you
found my magic deck and like because I
had like a 20-sided die I'm not deciding
your life on this dice this is how many
points I have us play and see if
anything shows up I guarantee you it's
just going to be like Teenage sweating
all that's going happen here that's so
funny my my parents for as religious as
they were media was just like not the
thing that they ever felt like needed
censoring which is so surprising music
absolutely but I'm like you don't know
what is in movies yeah that's why you're
wearing all your rebellious rock and
roll shirts now literally and if this is
rebellious that shows you just how much
like Ruckus I was putting par would be
with with putting on Feel Like Making
Love by Bad Company oh my God does you
kids leave the bedroom door open when
when you're studying hands everybody put
your hands Terry White from uh the
Empire magazine very well-known critic
was the one that actually wrote about
the craft which I think is crazy because
like this woman I think like she's the
editor that just edited that great piece
about Martin Scorsese where he's like
talking about his like morality like
this is the level that she kind of does
um I want to just at least point out the
fact that the music was a Bop yeah the
look was and if you were part of the
early days of the MTV TV movie awards
the raft is just like a movie of that
time like it's just I I can't say enough
about how I think it won the the popcorn
for for the fight scene think it won the
golden pop yeah they were throwing
Furniture so you really can't beat that
and the look we have what two people
well one person from um clueless we have
two people from Scream we have the Brady
Bunch movie I mean really
Ander movie when it came out I mean
again this movie was released May 3rd
that's like the first huge weekend of
the summer movie season and that's after
a Fast and Furious movies already come
out like mid April and it it was number
one I think it made like six million
bucks and it was number one and it edged
out a couple like you know holdovers um
Van Dam's the quest was number three I
did I did note that but there weren't
like a lot of other new movies that were
coming out which is crazy to think that
it was like May in 1996 and like this is
what we well all the money in Hollywood
was going towards that Titanic release
they were like we putting all of our
eggs in the James Cameron basket better
pray better Lu um also too I I want to
add with this one this was definitely a
movie that was a VHS phenomenon like
that was the thing about this one is
this was a movie that yeah because you
have a sleepover and you put it in and
you're doing you know you're probably
doing spells like the movie you know
lock the door so my parents can't catch
us watching this kind of thing totally
light as a feathers to VIs that sort of
like Candyman horror stuff this was uh
yeah this is the film that sort of plays
the soundtrack of it that wraps us up on
the movie talk we didn't mention the
sequel but there is one that came out in
2022 we briefly touched on the craft
Legacy which I I got to be honest I'm
interested yeah I just want to know
because it's called Legacy how much we
taken from from this one do we get to
meet our store owner again well she's
just in the opening scene like you know
who who's in the Legacy who's in Legacy
there's one that Nev's in it right one
of them back for
legacy either never go to the email and
I'll I'll have an answer on the other
side we we'll have an answer on the
other side let's go ahead and open our
mailbag while Mark looks up whether I've
lost my
[Music]
mind okay we have a mailbag this week
and this is from beatric Summer and she
says hey there my name is be sorry
beatric I want to suggest an episode for
us but I'm a Cheerleader girl you are
bringing the queer energy to the right
this is one of my favorite movies and I
think it's the reason it didn't get a
great Rotten Tomato score is because it
was way ahead of its time it's so funny
a perfect queer movie thank you so much
42% rotten with a 74% audience score
also one of our Essentials on queer
comedies Natasha Leon the movie that
made us think for so long that she was
not straight M But I'm a
Cheerleader Honestly though I think that
was probably one of the most
disappointing moments for a lot of women
was they found out that she was like
yeah I mean all the fan pages are like
what's going on like no not only is she
straight she's dating Fred Armon yeah
yeah I mean I I saw an interview um that
Greta gerwick did about Barbie and was
talking about all of the influences and
obviously there's so many but one of
them was but I'm a cheer leader and I
think that like even if you uh don't
relate to the story or you feel like
it's it's very of its time which it is
uh there's so much to be gained just by
the way they shot that film and how like
surreal it is but also like the color
palettes I just think that like it's a
movie that I I also saw later and I was
like holds up yeah no the dark themes
with her like ethereal pink the thing
about but I'm a che leader it's right
there in the title it is the shock when
you are not what everyone presents you
to be and like the movie exploring that
conceit in such like achingly authentic
detail is just why it's so great so yeah
maybe maybe I shouldn't see it because
like because i' I've gotten into comedy
clubs with the but I'm a comedian like
that kind of thing that insecurity tinge
we all feel yeah I didn't know Natasha
was in I mean I I heard of the movie
I've never seen it I didn't know Natasha
was in it I love everything she's done
and and recently she's had such a run
and like and I'm such a fan of hers so
I'm ready to go back I I think we should
absolutely right after we revisit the
craft Legacy starring let me give you
some names okay let me give you some
names uh Michelle Monahan is in this
David shows up Simone um there's Zoe
Luna there's people in this the one
recurring member that I see on here
maybe there's like a quick you know
blink if you miss a cameo I do not see
our storefront owner I do see uh fua is
is you know I would watch just I haven't
seen her in a minute I'd like to see
where we are and I want to see where she
is with that character because it's like
hey one time I got a little too Manning
crazy and I uh you know started doing
some bad stuff just a quick flashback to
her screaming right right that's a good
one one of these days I need to ask you
how many girls in your high school dress
like these girls but that's that's there
there there was a click and my sister
may or I would have been a part of it in
her grade she the head of it she might
have been my sister was doing a lot of
stuff that I had no idea Year we We
review I was like you were allowed to
drive me to basketball practice after
Mom knew you did this and this and like
it was yeah wow I mean I definitely had
like a friend who was like the coven
friend but again I was like in I don't
know fourth or fifth grade so she was
mostly like drawing vampires and stuff I
was like well Autumn's always been a
little strange that was just sort of how
we approached it um and then by the time
we were in high school we had just gone
different ways oh my God but I was
trying to think of like what's like the
dude equivalent of The Craft and it
really the only thing I can come up with
is American Pie cuz we're not as
sophisticated as y'all in high school
like we just want to get laid that's all
we're thinking about and meanwhile y'all
like doing like like spells all these
fun hobes like sports and chicks like
all we thinking mean but y'all put so
much effort into that boy do you really
made it an art a craft if you will and I
still make quite an effort in
sports the other one the shiing show
come all right Aila before you get out
of here first of all let folks know
where they can find you and what you
have working on that maybe you can tell
us because there nothing you can tell
good point um okay so I am on the
internet on Instagram Aila AK a i l a h
h I would say Twitter but like what is
that husk no one knows anymore you don't
have to go there I just I just post like
shows like like what I'm doing and but I
don't like engage at all there's no
point anymore and it doesn't work
functionally it does not work trying to
watch the Bengals game and I'm like okay
so these are from 12 hours ago the top
stuff is still from 12 hours ago the
game is on actively um Halloween colors
with with your Cincinnati Bengals orange
and black we love um and then yeah I
mean I have a book called obviously
stories from my timeline it's been out
for a while four year anniversary go
check it out and I have a podcast in the
works that uh is about my high school
and going back so I guess the craft sort
of feels similar I'm like what was going
on where we were mostly the confederate
general that was our
mascot where did you go to school
Kentucky uh it was Boon County High
School our in Kentucky and our mascot
was Mr Rebel oh boy oh my mother went to
Roberty Lee High School I will raise you
a named one not just just not just in a
Rob Lee High School robe high school I
love the mascot Please Mr Rebel's my
father you can re little Jesus uh have
you been watching anything you want to
recommend for us oh I mean what a great
question you know I think we're almost
allowed to we're so close I know we're
so close I'm in a rewatch phase right
now so if you've never seen Bojack
Horsemen I guess go back in town wow you
have been on strike cuz that is some of
the most depressing stuff it's been hard
I honestly forgot that there was going
to be an industry this has reminded me
of like movies were a thing we used to
yeah yeah we were we used to do that we
were I had never seen Bojack Horsemen
and I got to this was probably I don't
know a couple years ago but then I I had
to bench it because I was interviewing
the Creator here in the studio and man
it's it's it's phenomenal it's a
phenomenal show it gets dark though it
gets dark the darkest but very comedian
sensibility kind of dark actually I was
going to say this is very much in your
wheelhouse but that is all for this
wheel house on the craft today Aila it's
so glad that you finally made it to the
Pod and bringing all of your hilarity Mr
Mark Sir is there the when this comes
out won't you be in New York I'll
probably be in New York telling jokes
New York comedy club um so got some
headlining shows there and then later on
this year I got Seattle I got San Diego
uh Boston DC early next year so just
enough tour dates to keep me keep me
busy keep me uh honing my craft or to
keep you questionable on how many girls
are in different yeah well you
know I just got back from the most
boring week you'd ever want to do in
Vegas in different area I had options in
Vegas I had options you had options Opa
them pasta and lobster
and he's out there he's out there he's
coming to your city but you on my pasta
and you on my
lster gorgeous
stunning we've done
it this is oh sorry oh my God I was very
well behaved yes you shouldn't be though
listen actually you know what I did I
mentioned on the last podcast too is I'd
come back to my room after the show
right you meet a bunch of people and you
get some hey what are you doing later
and I would I would light my candle and
I'd watch Friends on Nick and night oh
my God he would he would light his
pumpin candle put on friends and he
wants to get mad at me for calling him
slightly B I got it a it was a sweater
weather candle
at
body even better even better that wraps
it up for this week please tune in next
week Mark let them know what the episode
is because my excitement is just too
much oh my goodness another one that I
haven't seen all these gaps in my
knowledge being filled including uh the
1985 classic Legend yeah oh wow these
are the let's be honest this this is the
one that I've been like early Tom Cruz
that Legend I may have part of it
tattooed on me ooh really okay so we'll
do the tattoo reveal and we'll do the
reveal the Tomato an unfinished tattoo
actually but yes isn't every tattoo
unfinished it is have you ever met
somebody and they're like well it's well
it's completely finished like nobody
ever says that this the beginning and
end of my tattoo very beginning of it
but no I love
Legend uh with a great soundtrack
everyone should listen to it to get
prepared tune in next week thank you for
Brian Brian Perez rson Mr Tim Ryan Mark
Ellis and Aila Hughes I'm Jaclyn Coley
and we'll see y'all next next time
[Music]
[Applause]
bye